um
so
so
i'll be sure there's no more
so
so
good morning
good morning president salovey provost
[ __ ] dean pollard
secretary goff cruz
chaplain coogler
masters deans and honored guests
and welcome women and men of the class
of 2017.
welcome
welcome to yale university and welcome
to yale college
i'm well all of us we're so excited to
have you here we've been thinking about
you since april when the dean of
admissions told us your names
then we met some of you during bulldog
days we met a few more of you this week
in orientation programs but at last
class of 2017 you are here welcome
inside the walls onto the playing fields
into the classrooms and the residential
colleges welcome
welcome to the spaces and places you
will soon call home
and welcome to all the families and
friends who have brought you to this day
you've come from berlin connecticut and
berlin
from guadalajara to grindelwald to
guangzhou
from tokyo and topeka
thanks for having helped 1
360
of the world's most interesting and
smartest young men and women find their
way to today
we are going to have exceptional
encounters with them over the next few
years in the classroom the dining halls
intramural fields and extracurricular
activities
let me add that we plan to have plenty
of fun along the way
but
2017 back to you
you have arrived at a campus that
witnessed an amazing transformation last
year
when the yale university art gallery
reopened after more than a decade of
rethinking what a museum and
particularly a university museum should
be like in the 21st century
it is now a complex of buildings that
hold a vastly expanded compendium of
some of the world's most remarkable and
famous works of art
the media went wild over the new museum
and now people come from all over the
world to see the amazing collection of
things
for which the maker came to the task
trained in his or her craft
resulting in extraordinary outcome and
which are imbued with meaning
each painting
each sculpture
each thing
in the art gallery exemplifies what paul
clay said
art does not reproduce what we see
rather
it makes us see
yet here's an astonishing number
most art historians and i am one would
estimate that 99
of all such works ever made
are lost to us
99
some are deliberately and willfully
destroyed for economic political
religious
and personal reasons
from tapestries burnt to yield their
gold and silver threads
to the implosion of the giant buddhas of
afghanistan to the recent rumor of
impressionist paintings burned to cover
the tracks of thieves
those objects had been part of the one
percent to survive
and now they are lost to us forever
but even without such human intervention
the survival of powerful charismatic
works is a dicey matter
fires floods and most of all time itself
do their damage especially given that
most works on canvas or paper or made of
wood or fabric
are perishable or fugitive
left to the elements
works of art vanish
often leaving no trace so it is not
surprising that most of the objects i
study from the prehispanic past of
mexico and central america
are those that were made of fired clay
or stone the two most enduring materials
humans have ever worked
you have a picture in front of you
you might want to take it out have a
look you have a picture in front of you
of an object that is on display now
at the yale art gallery although as i
will explain in just a minute it is in
fact part of the peabody museum
collection across campus
it's an aztec carving from just about
the time of the spanish invasion of
mexico in 1519.
images of this sort were made much of
last december at the time that the maya
calendar was reaching what hollywood and
the tabloids in the checkout aisle
commonly called the mayan apocalypse but
let me set you straight
no ancient maya ever used such an image
it's aztec
you look at the picture in front of you
and you immediately recognize that
you're looking at an image of the sun
it's rays shooting out from a nearly
perfect circle
this carved stone
came to rest in new haven in 1887
when something called the aztec fair
a knockoff of more popular traveling
carnival pageants like buffalo bill's
wild west show
came to town
only to go bankrupt here
the saleable assets were auctioned at a
share of sale where the founding
director of yale's peabody museum
purchased it and about a decade later he
gave it to the museum
although almost all aztec works of the
period of when which this comes from um
had been destroyed
especially the figural ones thought to
be at the heart of aztec religion
a few fortunate but battered stone
sculptures did survive
often because they were useful the great
calendar stone a much larger version of
a work closely related to the one you
are looking at was set face down in
mexico city's main square to serve as a
convenient paving stone for 250 years
only through deep excavations in the
past few years have archaeologists at
the city center begun to recover a small
corpus
recovering
more aztec works recently than in the
previous 450 years
the survival of the stone in front of
you is a token of both serendipity and
durability
what does the stone itself say
it claims that the four previous eras of
the earth have ended in disaster in
which the sun collapses and humans all
vanish
each era named by the four dots and a
glyph at the corners
starting in the upper left and moving
counterclockwise
for jaguar
when jaguar marauders ate the sun
causing an earth-ending eclipse
for wind when hurricanes destroyed the
world and blew humans into trees turning
them into monkeys
for water when floods annihilated the
earth
and for rain when a volcanic rain of
fire brought the earth to an end the
sign at the center is of movement
the name of the era for movement in
which the aztecs lived an era predicted
to end in earthquakes
which would cause the sun to fall and to
collapse for all eternity
quite honestly its message is audacious
for it's an aztec cosmos sustained by
human sacrifice that keeps this fifth
sun in place
held up by the starry heavens marked
along the four sides
one more battered bit this carved stone
served at the aztec fair in 1887
as backdrop to a story an entertainer
recounted to the citizens of new haven
of how a captured prisoner became a
gladiator tied to this stone fending off
all comers but refusing to join his
aztec captors
having survived some 400 odd years
before arriving at yale
the aztec stone was put on view at the
old peabody museum
then located at the corner of elm and
high streets now the home of sabre
college saybrook isn't here right now
but i think they will enjoy finding this
out
i like to imagine that it might have
been on view right about where the
kitchen of the master's house now is
and so the stone and i who served as
master of sabre college for a decade
spent 10 years in the same space
100 years apart
the aztec stone also survived the 1907
collapse of part of the old peabody when
reportedly a number of exhibits were
destroyed
the new peabody the current one would
open in 1925.
now just one year ago the stone came to
the yale art gallery for its new
exhibition of pre-columbian art
the page you have in front of you is
from the 1910 article by yale
anthropologist george grant mccurdy
he had spent six years working his way
through a teacher's college in missouri
and after a stint of teaching and
serving as a school superintendent he
found his way to
harvard
harvard
where he had to earn another bachelor's
degree
in order to pursue graduate work in
biology and zoology he then became a
curator at the peabody museum with a key
role in its educational mission with
interests that ranged from the aztecs to
the ancient andes mccurdy focused his
attention by and large on the origins of
mankind
his 1924 book human origins is now a
fossil of its own mccurdy died before
the earliest hominids would be
recognized in africa but he would play a
role in the opening exhibition at the
peabody that sent shockwaves across the
united states
in the wake of the scope's monkey trial
in the summer of 1921
in which the state of tennessee had
successfully prosecuted a public school
teacher for teaching darwin's theories
the peabody would open a few months
later with an exhibition that displayed
human evolution descending from great
apes
in a full commitment to science and
education
the aztec stone was hardly noted in the
hubbub
that followed
but the art gallery has now given the
aztec stone
a featured setting
and it gives us a new way to enter a
lost belief system in a new context
it takes on a new life because of where
it is
not only among other works from mexico
but also now among the one percent of
exceptional things works of art to
survive
gathered into one building
these works that bear an intensity of
compression
like a poem
like a mathematical formula
any of these things
a work of art
a verse
a formula
compresses vast amounts of information
and thought as well as history
your task
your opportunity here at yale and in
life
is to stop
to screen out all other distractions so
that you can investigate discover
and interpret each one
in light of your understanding
emulate this verse from the poem
where does the temple begin where does
it end
by mary oliver
i look
morning tonight i am never done with
looking looking i mean not just standing
around but standing around as though
with your arms open
the place you have come to has an
extraordinary number of powerful
treasures unique charismatic things and
like you
they come from all parts of the world
some of them are in the beinecke library
where president salovey and i along with
our spouses will greet you later this
morning
more of them are in our amazing art and
natural history museums
in our collection of rare musical
instruments
and in our libraries
let them become part of you
and let discovery guide your life
and so i close by saying to you
class of 2017
open your arms
open your eyes
embrace seeing
embrace learning
so
foreign
good morning dean miller
colleagues on the platform
friends parents
other relatives
and of course members of the class of
2017.
it's an honor as yale's new president to
say these words
which i know you and your parents
your families and your friends have
waited quite some time to hear
welcome to yale
have something in common with you today
because i too
am a freshman
although i've been on campus for more
than three decades
this is in fact my first freshman
address as the president of this
inspiring university
like you i'm feeling a little bit
nervous a bit humble
certainly excited
like you i also spent too much time this
week
speaking
and not sleeping and now find myself
with laryngitis so
perhaps that fits some of you too
i know
that like you
our parents are feeling quite proud of
us today
you know as the saying goes
behind every new yearly
is a stunned parent
each of you arrived at yale with your
own story and i look forward to hearing
them
this morning though i'd like to begin
by telling you the story of my father
it's a story that many americans share
and that i know
many of you share
in fact we actually sang about it just a
few moments ago in the beautiful hymn
written by a member of the yale class of
1820
oh god beneath thy guiding hand our
exiled fathers crossed the sea
laws freedom truth and faith came with
those exiles or the waves that's what we
just sang
now my father's parents my grandparents
they came to the united states by way of
warsaw
and jerusalem
they actually first met each other on a
ship across the atlantic
in the midst of their journey between
their old and their new worlds
together they lived on the lower east
side of new york
spent a little time in chicago and ended
up in the bronx
where my father was raised
like many immigrants my grandparents
were poor in means
but rich in culture and spirit
my grandmother worked as a bookkeeper
and after my grandfather lost his small
store during the depression
he took care of the elderly and the
infirm
but today i stand before you a professor
of psychology
and president of one of the world's
finest universities no the finest
university
today i stand before you humbled
because i know
that there are very few places in the
world where in two generations
a family can rise from modest means
to this kind of role in life
how did it happen
the answer to that question in my family
i am sure resembles the answer in many
of yours
growing up in a small apartment in the
bronx my grandparents encouraged my
father to take education seriously
as with at least two of you here this
morning
he attended the bronx high school of
science
a fantastic public school
and then city college of new york
and brooklyn college
ultimately he received a doctorate in
chemistry from harvard
well nobody's
perfect all of this education
all of it
was without financial cost
to my father's family
in a country where opportunity was
within reach for both the rich and the
poor my grandparents values launched my
father toward a career as a polymer
chemist
at bell labs and later as a professor at
the university of southern california
and this education allowed my own
childhood to be decidedly middle class
and free for the most part from
financial worry
my father's personal dream to be a
scientist
regardless of how or where he grew up
this is the american dream as well
study hard
work hard and you will be rewarded by
social and economic mobility
because of education
the ladder of opportunity was it was
within reach for my father
of course this dream is not unique to
america
those of you who come to yale from
overseas about 10 percent of your class
may have experienced a version of the
american dream in your own country
and in your own family
from the bronx to budapest
from san diego to seoul
there is a common understanding that
transcends borders
of the power of
education in fact on a recent trip to
asia i heard the phrase chinese dream
many times
and it signified in part the very idea
i'm talking about now
for the purposes of these remarks though
i'll use the phrase american dream
and this morning
i worry
about whether the american dream is
still possible
and whether education
is still the best ticket
to socioeconomic mobility
is it still as the historian who made
popular the idea of the american dream
wrote in 1931 is it still a dream of a
land in which life
should be better and richer and fuller
for everyone with opportunity for each
according to ability or achievement
a dream of being able to grow
to fullest development as man and woman
unhampered
by the barriers which had slowly been
erected in the older civilizations
unrepressed by social orders which had
developed for the benefit of classes
rather than for the simple human being
of any
and every class
higher education has been viewed in
american history as the vehicle
by which to pursue this dream
and to improve one's personal
circumstances
as it was with my first gen father
but it is an idea as old as america
itself
for as thomas jefferson wrote
if the condition of man is to be
progressively
ameliorated as we fondly hope and
believe
education is to be the tree chief
instrument in affecting it
that is why even after writing the
declaration of independence
after serving as america's first
secretary of state
second vice president and third
president
jefferson would later say that founding
the university of virginia was the
accomplishment about which he felt the
most pride
this same vision this same emphasis on
education
has motivated progressive legislation
from the moral acts which created the
land grant colleges to the gi bill
to title iv and the federal pell grant
program
these investments are worth making
because college graduates develop broad
and deep knowledge
sharp critical thinking
and communication skills
and the ability to work collaboratively
and as a result they are three times as
likely as those without a degree
to move from the lowest levels of family
income to the top level
though the american dream is deeply
rooted in our history
it is not a
guarantee it is something that must be
product protected
and preserved
and passed on with care
to the next generation
and yet
in recent years
this dream has been tested
college completion
has increased
but only among families in the top half
of the income distribution and not among
the bottom half
another threat to the american dream was
revealed by the economists carolyn hoxby
and christopher avery
they found that many high achieving
students from less well-off families do
not even apply to the very best colleges
and universities especially if they are
from smaller more rural parts of the
country
these students do not know anyone who
has attended a place like yale and they
do not think a place like yale
is for them
their families do not know that
need-based financial aid is available
and that they would contribute far less
than the sticker price of many other
colleges and universities of many of the
colleges and universities in this
country
why did i choose to talk about yale
and the american dream today
to assure you especially those of you
from families that are not affluent
that the agree that the dream
is very much alive and well
here at yale
ten years after they graduated members
of the yell class of 1998
reported impressive and similar
average salaries and
a higher level of life satisfaction
regardless of whether they came from
families whose standard of living was
far below average
below average
average
or above average
yale has seen its has seen socioeconomic
mobility as a central pillar of its
mission since its earliest days
the eminent yale historian george w
pearson
a man whose love for yale and her
history garnered him the honorary title
father yale
wrote
half the boys in each colonial class
were from families of no social standing
in the 19th century yell continued to
attract and to care for many of the most
modest means
and tuition was religiously kept low
by 1850
it was just 39
sorry parents
a yale student named david avery noted
in 1768
there appears to be a laudable ambition
to excel in knowledge
it is not he that has got the finest
coat or largest ruffles that is esteemed
here at present
the students may expect marks of
distinction to be put upon the best
scholars and speakers
now let me pause here and note
that we should all be relieved that
having the largest ruffles is no longer
a sign of superiority
i say say that a little self-consciously
though
i raised the issue of social mobility
because if you have any doubt
that the american dream still lives on
today
if you like me
wonder
whether someone like my father
could fulfill his dreams
just look around you
look at yourselves
look at the students next to you
they have different talents and ideas
from you
different family backgrounds from you
but each of you have worked incredibly
hard
to make it here
if you have any doubt that the american
dream lives on
gays class of 2017 gaze into the eyes of
your parents
they know
looking back at you here today
that the unthinkable
is still possible
but let me mention something that is
just a bit more difficult to discuss
you class of 2017
bring your different cultures different
religions different ethnicities
different sexual orientations to this
campus
and as any yale student will tell you
one of yale's most inspiring qualities
is that yellies are quite comfortable
discussing these differences
but you are also
an economically diverse group
some of you hail from families of
limited means
and others
from great abundance
most of you are from families somewhere
in between
and yet
these differences remain just below the
surface
roommates become aware of these
disparities of course
but they are uncomfortable talking about
them and sharing
what their lives were like prior to
attending yale
i believe that talking about
socioeconomic status is one of the last
taboos among yale students
when the issue of money comes up
students are often profoundly
uncomfortable
this is understandable
yale
is such a great equalizer most of the
time
that when it comes to money people may
feel guilty
if they think they have more than
someone else
or embarrassed if they have less
some of you will hold a work study job
others will not
some of you will be able to travel
overseas during spring break
others not
some of you can afford to accept unpaid
internships in the summer others of you
cannot
when you decide to purchase a sofa for
your common room or make plans to eat in
one of new haven's wonderful restaurants
some of your roommates will not think
twice about doing so
but for others it will be a financial
stretch
perhaps too large a one
yell has taken many measures to try to
find ways to equalize the college
experience
gone are the days when students spent
many many hours waiting tables or going
hungry
still
differences exist
and it makes little sense to pretend
they do not
and little sense to think yale can
obliterate all distinctions or make
everything possible
for those who do not have as much as
others
to the class of 2017 i encourage you
to be sensitive
and open to one another
you will meet students here from all
walks of life
the uncomfortable conversations that you
will certainly have in commons or in
your common room
represent opportunities for true
understanding and true friendship with
classmates whose families may be far
different
from your own
one of our college masters told me about
two students in his college
one
felt so guilty about his family's wealth
that he refused ever to invite any
friends home
and his parents complained about this to
the master
in that same college another student now
graduated was ashamed that she had grown
up in a tin shack
and she hid this from all of her friends
at the end of her time at yale her
friend's friend found out the truth
about her background
she was stunned and relieved to know
that instead of thinking less of her
they thought more of her for triumphing
triumphing over challenging
circumstances
this is what yellies are like
although after all there are hard
aspects of life
but they could be made less difficult
however by the openness and sharing for
which yale students are generally
so well known
yale students pearson wrote are not
loners
not solitary
they are part of each other
as a product of the american dream
myself
i am inspired by it
i am committed to preserving it
and while admitting that it has been
idealized historically and perhaps
compromised in contemporary society i am
convinced that yours can be the
generation
that ensures it is kept alive and i mean
that whether you come from pittsburgh or
pretoria or ponce
i am thankful that yale's financial aid
policies and practices sustain and
propel this promise
and allow so many of you access
to the american dream
but more than that
i am thankful that a yale education
helps to develop the habits of mind and
behavior
that will first lead you to
uncomfortable
and challenging conversations
but then motivate you
to make constructive contributions
to your professions
and to your families
to your countries
and to the world
yours can be
the generation that helps to develop a
more complex vision of the american
dream
one that both moves beyond social
mobility and also includes living a life
of growth
of meaning
of significance
affordable education and opportunities
for fulfilling work are essential for
this vision
it is my hope
indeed it is my conviction
that you will continue to ensure
that the dream of a better life
will be woven permanently
into the fabric of our societies
around the world
so
however it is that you arrived here at
yale
on behalf
of all of my colleagues on the platform
this morning
welcome parents
welcome families
welcome
class
of 2017.
thanks
thanks very much
oh
foreign
oh
is
foreign
yeah us
my sisters and brothers
as we prepare to step out onto new
ground
into this daunting
yet inspiring liminal space
of the unknown next we begin a poignant
turn of goodbyes and hellos that invite
laughter tears
discovery and pride
let us go forth
with deep trust in certain knowledge
that love surrounds us
that beauty can surprise us
that truth and light awaits us
on this day and evermore
may all that is holy shine upon us
and tenderly
bless our every breath
may we go in shalom
in salam
in shanti
in peace amen
good morning good morning president
salovey provost [ __ ]
dean pollard
chaplain coogler secretary golf cruz
masters
deans and honored guests
and welcome women and men of the class
of 2017.
welcome
welcome to yale university and welcome
to yale college
i'm well all of us we're so excited to
have you here we've been thinking about
you since april when the dean of
admissions told us your names
then we met some of you during bulldog
days we met a few more of you this week
in orientation programs but at last
class of 2017 you are here
welcome inside the walls onto the
playing fields into the classrooms and
the residential colleges welcome
welcome to the spaces and places you
will soon call home
and welcome to all the friends and
family who have brought you to this day
you've come from berlin connecticut and
berlin
from guadalajara to grunevalt to
guangzhou
from tokyo
and topeka
thanks for having helped 1
360
of the world's most interesting and
smartest young women and men
find their way to today
we are going to have exceptional
encounters with them over the next few
years in the classroom in the dining
halls
on the intramural fields in
extracurricular activities
let me add that we plan to have plenty
of fun along the way
but 2017 back to you
you have arrived at a campus that
witnessed an amazing transformation last
year when the yale university art
gallery reopened after more than a
decade of rethinking what a museum and
particularly a university museum should
be like in the 21st century
it is now a complex of buildings that
hold a vastly expanded compendium of
some of the world's most remarkable and
famous works of art
the media went wild over the new museum
and now people come from all over the
world to see the amazing collection of
things for which the maker came to the
task trained in his or her craft
resulting an extraordinary outcome
and then imbuing the thing with meaning
each painting each sculpture each thing
in the art gallery exemplifies what
painter paul clay said
art does not reproduce what we see
rather it makes us see
yet here's an astonishing number
most art historians and i am one
would estimate that 99 percent
of all such works ever made are lost to
us
some are deliberately and willfully
destroyed for economic political
religious or personal reasons
from tapestries burnt to yield their
gold and silver threads
to the implosion of the giant buddhas of
afghanistan to the recent rumor of
impressionist paintings burn
burned to cover the tracks of thieves
those objects had been part of the one
percent to survive and now they are lost
to us forever
but even without such human intervention
the survival of powerful charismatic
works is a dicey matter
floods
fires and most of all time itself do
their damage especially given that most
works on canvas or paper or made of wood
or fabric
are perishable or fugitive
left to the elements
works of art vanish
often leaving no trace
so it is not surprising that most of the
objects i study from the prehispanic
past of mexico and central america
are those that were made of fired clay
or stone the two most enduring materials
humans have ever worked
you have a picture in front of you
and this is of an object that is now on
display
at the yale art gallery
although as i will explain in a minute
it is in fact part of the peabody museum
collection from across campus
it's an aztec carving from just about
the time of the spanish invasion of
mexico in 1519
images of the sort were made much of
last december at the time that the maya
calendar was reaching what hollywood and
the tabloids commonly called the mayan
apocalypse
but let me set you straight
no ancient maya ever used such an image
it's aztec
you look at the picture in front of you
and you immediately recognize that
you're looking at an image of the sun
it's rays shooting out from a nearly
perfect circle
and the other pieces of the picture are
the sides that have been folded up so
you can see the whole thing at once
this carved stone
came to rest in new haven in 1887 when
the aztec fair
a knockoff of more popular traveling
carniv carnival pageants like buffalo
bill's wild west show came to town
only to go bankrupt here
the saleable assets were auctioned at
what was called a sheriff's sale
where the founding director of yale's
peabody museum purchased it
and about a decade later he gave it to
the museum
although almost all aztec works of the
period of the spanish invasion had been
destroyed especially the figural ones
thought to be at the heart of aztec
religion a few fortunate but battered
stone sculptures did survive
often because they were useful
the great aztec calendar stone a much
larger version of a work closely related
to the one you are looking at was set
face down in mexico city's main square
to function as a convenient paving stone
for at least 250 years
only through deep excavations in the
past few years have archaeologists at
the city center
begun to expand a small corpus
recovering more aztec works recently
than in the previous 450 years
the survival of the stone in front of
you is a token of both serendipity and
durability
what does the stone say
it claims that the four previous eras of
the earth have ended in disaster in
which the sun collapses and humans
vanish
each era named by the four dots and a
glyph at the corners the corners of the
central image
starting in the upper left and moving
counterclockwise
for jaguar
when jaguar marauders ate the sun
causing an earth-ending eclipse
for wind when hurricanes destroyed the
world and blew humans into trees turning
them into monkeys
for water when floods annihilated the
earth
and for rain when a volcanic rain of
fire brought the earth to an end
the sign at the center is of movement
the name of the era for movement in
which the aztecs lived an era predicted
to end in earthquakes causing the sun to
fall and to collapse for all eternity
quite honestly its message is audacious
for the it is an aztec cosmos sustained
by human sacrifice that keeps this fifth
sun in place
held up by the starry heavens marked
along the four sides
one more battered bit
this carved stone
served at the aztec fair in 1887
as a backdrop to a story an entertainer
recounted to the citizens of new haven
of how a captured prisoner became a
gladiator
tied to the stone fending off all comers
but refusing to join his aztec captors
having survived some 400 odd years
before arriving at yale the aztec stone
was put on view at the old peabody
museum
then located at the corner of elman high
streets now the home of saber college
i like to imagine that it might have
been on view right about where the
kitchen of the master's house now is and
so the stone and i who served as sabrik
master for a decade spent 10 years in
the same space 100 years apart
the aztec stone
survived the 1907 collapse of part of
the peabody
museum when reportedly a number of
exhibits were destroyed the new peabody
the current peabody would open in 1925.
now one year ago the stone came to the
yale university art gallery for its new
exhibition of pre-columbian art
the page you have in front of you
is from the 1910 article by
anthropologist george grant mccurdy
he had spent six years working his way
through a teacher's college in missouri
and after a stint of teaching and
serving as a school superintendent found
his way to
harvard
harvard
where he had to earn another bachelor's
degree
in order to pursue graduate work in
biology and zoology
he then became a curator at yale's
peabody museum with a key role in its
educational mission
with interests that ranged from the
aztecs to the ancient andes mccurdy
focused his attention on the origins of
mankind his 1924 book human origins is
now a fossil of its own mccurdy died
before the earliest hominids would be
recognized in africa
but he would play a role in the opening
exhibition at the peabody an exhibition
that sent shockwaves across the united
states
in the wake
of the scope's monkey trial in the
summer of 1925
in which the state of tennessee had
successfully prosecuted a public school
teacher for teaching darwin's theories
the peabody would open a few months
later with an exhibition that displayed
human evolution from the great apes
in a full commitment to science and
education
the aztec stone
was hardly noted in the hubbub that
followed
but the art gallery has now given the
aztec stone a featured setting and it
gives us a way to enter a lost belief
system in a new context
it takes on a new life because of where
it is
not only among other works from mexico
but also now among the one other one
percent
of exceptional things works of art to
survive
gathered into one building
these works that bear an intensity of
compression
like a poem
like a mathematical formula
any of these things
a work of art a verse
a formula
compresses vast amounts of information
and thought
as well as history
your task
your opportunity here at yale and in
life
is to stop
to screen out all other distractions so
that you can study
investigate discover
and interpret each one in light of your
understanding
emulate this verse from the poem
where does the temple begin
where does it end
by mary oliver
i look
morning to night i am never done with
looking
looking i mean not just standing around
but standing around as though with your
arms open
the place you have come to
has an extraordinary number of powerful
treasures
unique
charismatic things
and like you they come from all parts of
the world
some of them are in the beineckey
library
where president salovey and i
along with our spouses will greet you in
a few minutes
more of them are in our amazing art and
natural history museums
in our collection
of rare musical instruments
and in our libraries
let them become part of you
and let discovery
guide your life
and so
i close by saying to you
class of 2017
open your arms
open your eyes
embrace seeing
embrace
learning
um
just
foreign
um
so
good morning dean miller and
colleagues on the platform
friends
parents other relatives
and members of the class of 2017.
it is an honor
as yells new president to say these
three words
which i know you and your parents
your families
and friends
have waited quite some time to hear
welcome to yell
i have something in common with you
because i too am a freshman today
although i've been on this campus for
more than three decades
this is in fact my very first freshman
address
as the president
of this inspiring university
like you
i'm feeling a little nervous
a bit humbled
but certainly excited
and like you
i did a little too much talking this
week and not enough sleeping
and now have laryngitis
and like you
i know that our parents are feeling
quite proud of us today
you know as the saying goes behind every
new yelly
is a stunned parent
each of you arrived at yale with your
own story and i look forward to hearing
them this morning
i would like to begin by telling you the
story
of my father
it's a story that many americans share
and that i know many of you share
in fact we actually sang about it just a
few moments ago
in the beautiful hymn
written by a member of the yale class of
1820
oh god beneath thy guiding hand our
exiled fathers crossed the sea
laws freedom truth and faith came with
those exiles over the waves
my father's parents my grandparents
came to the united states by way of
warsaw and jerusalem
they actually first met each other on a
ship across the atlantic
in the midst of their journey
between their old
and their new worlds
together they lived on the lower east
side of new york
spent a little time in chicago
and then ended up in the bronx
where my father was raised
like many immigrants
my grandparents were poor in means
but rich in culture
and spirit
my grandmother worked as a bookkeeper
and after my grandfather lost his small
store during the depression
he took care of the elderly and the
infirm
but today
i stand before you
a professor of psychology
and president
of one of the world's finest
universities
the finest university
today
i stand before you humbled
because i know that there are very few
places in the world where in two
generations
a family can rise from modest means to
this kind of role in life
how did it happen
the answer to that question in my family
i am sure resembles the answer
in many of yours
growing up in a small apartment in the
bronx
my grandparents encouraged my father to
take education seriously
as with at least two of you here today
he attended the bronx high school of
science
a fantastic public school
and then the city college of new york
and brooklyn college
ultimately
he received a doctorate in chemistry
from harvard
well nobody's perfect
all of this education
all of it
was without financial cost
to my father's family
in a country where opportunity was
within reach for both the rich and the
poor
my grandparents values launched my
father
toward a career as a polymer chemist at
bell labs and later as a professor at
the university of southern california
and this education
allowed my own childhood
to be decidedly middle class and free
for the most part from financial worry
my father's personal dream to be a
scientist
regardless of how or where he grew up
this is the american dream as well
study hard
work hard
and you will be rewarded by social and
economic mobility
because of education the latter of
opportunity was in was within reach
for my father
of course
this dream is not unique to america
those of you who come to yale from
overseas about 10 percent of your class
may have experienced a version of the
american dream in your own country
and in your own family
from the bronx
to budapest
from san diego
to seoul
there is a common understanding
that transcends borders
of the power
of education
in fact on a recent trip to asia
i heard the phrase chinese dream many
times
and it signified in part
the very idea i'm talking about now
for the purposes of these remarks though
i will use the phrase american dream
and this morning i worry
about whether the american dream is
still possible
and whether education
is still the best ticket
to socioeconomic mobility
is it still
as the historian who made popular the
idea of the american dream wrote in
1931 is it still
a dream of a land
in which life should be better and
richer and fuller for everyone
with opportunity for each
according to ability
or achievement
a dream of being able to grow to fullest
development as man and woman
unhampered
by the barriers which had slowly been
erected in the older civilizations
unrepressed by social orders which had
developed developed for the benefit of
classes
rather
than for the simple human being of any
and every class
higher education
has been viewed in american history
as the vehicle by which to pursue this
dream
and to improve
one's personal circumstances
as it was with my first gen father
it is an idea
as old as america itself
as thomas jefferson wrote
if the condition of man is to be
progressively ameliorated as we fondly
hope and believe
education is to be the chief instrument
in affecting it
that is why even after writing the
declaration of independence after
serving as america's first secretary of
state second vice president and third
president
jefferson would later say that founding
the university of virginia was the
accomplishment about which he felt the
most pride
this same vision
this same emphasis on education
has
motivated progressive legislation from
the moral acts that created the land
grant colleges
to the gi bill
to title iv and the federal pell grant
program
these investments are worth making
because college graduates develop broad
and deep knowledge
sharp critical thinking and
communication skills and the ability to
work
collaboratively
and as a result
they're three times as likely as those
without a degree
to move from the lowest levels of family
income to the top level
though the american dream is deeply
rooted in our history
it is not a guarantee
it is something that must be protected
and preserved
and passed on with care
to the next generation
and yet in recent years
this dream has been tested
college completion
has increased only among families in the
top half of the income distribution
and not
among the bottom half
another threat to the american dream was
revealed by the economists carolyn
hocksby and christopher avery
they found that many high achieving
students from less well-off families do
not even apply
to the very best colleges and
universities
especially if they are from smaller more
rural parts of the country
these students do not know anyone who
has attended a place like yale
and they do not think a place like yale
is for them
their families did not know that
need-based financial aid is available
and that they would contribute far less
than the sticker price
of many colleges and universities in
this country
why did i choose to talk about yale and
the american dream today
to assure you
especially those of you from families
that are not affluent
that the dream is very much alive
here at yale
ten years after they graduated
members of the class the yale college
class of 1998
reported impressive and similar
average salaries
and
a higher level of life satisfaction
regardless
of whether they came from families whose
standard of living was far below average
below average average or above average
yale has seen socioeconomic mobility as
a central pillar of its mission
since its earliest days
the eminent yale historian george w
pearson
a man whose love for yale and her
history garnered him the honorary title
father yale
wrote
half the boys in each colonial class
were from families of no social standing
in the 19th century yale continued to
attract and to care for many of the most
modest means
and tuition was religiously kept low
by eighteen fifty
it was just thirty nine dollars
sorry parents
a yale student named david avery noted
in 1768
there appears to be a laudable ambition
to excel in knowledge
it is not
he that has got the finest coat
or the largest ruffles
that is esteemed here at present
the students may expect marks of
distinction
to be put upon the best scholars and
speakers
let me pause here and note
that we should all be relieved that
having the largest ruffles is no longer
a sign of superiority
say that slightly self-consciously
i raise the issue of social mobility
because if you have any doubt
that the american dream still lives on
today
if you like me
wonder whether someone like my father
could fulfill his dreams
just look around you
look at yourselves
look at the students next to you
they have different talents and ideas
from you
different family backgrounds from you
but each of you
worked incredibly hard
to make it here
if you have any doubt that the american
dream lives on
i ask you class of 2017
gaze into the eyes of your parents
they know
looking back
at you
here today
that the unthinkable is still possible
but let me mention something
that is just a bit more difficult to
discuss
you class of 2017
bring your different cultures
religions
ethnicities and sexual orientations to
this campus
and as any yale student will tell you
one of yale's most inspiring qualities
is that yalies are quite comfortable
discussing these differences
but you are also
an economically diverse group
some of you hail from families of
limited means
and others from great abundance
most of you are from families somewhere
in between
and yet
these differences remain just below the
surface
roommates become aware of these
disparities of course
but they are often uncomfortable talking
about them
and sharing what their lives were like
prior to attending yale
i believe that talking about
socioeconomic status is one of the last
taboos among yale students
when the issue of money comes up
students are often profoundly
uncomfortable
this is understandable
yale is such a great equalizer most of
the time that when it comes to money
people may feel guilty if they think
they have more than someone else
or embarrassed if they have less
some of you
will hold a work study job
others of you will not
some of you will be able to travel
overseas during spring break
others not
some of you can afford to accept unpaid
internships in the summer others of you
cannot
when you decide to purchase a sofa for
your common room
or make plans to eat in one of new
haven's wonderful restaurants
some of you some of your roommates will
not think twice about doing so
but for others it will be a financial
stretch
perhaps
too large of one
yale has taken many measures to try to
find ways to equalize the college
experience
gone are the days when students spent
many many hours waiting tables or going
hungry
still
differences exist
and it makes little sense to pretend
that they don't
and little sense
to think that yale can obliterate all
distinctions or make everything possible
for those who do not have as much as
others
to the class of 2017
i encourage you to be sensitive and open
to one another
you will meet students here from all
walks of life
the uncomfortable conversations that you
will certainly have
in commons or in your common room
represent opportunities for true
understanding
and true friendship
true friendship with classmates whose
families are far different from your own
one of our college masters told me about
two students in his college
one one felt so guilty about his
family's wealth
that he refused to invite any friends
home
and his parents complained about this to
the master
in that same college
another student now graduated
was ashamed that she had grown up in a
tin shack
and she hid this
from her friends
at the end of her time at yale her
friends found out they found out the
truth
about her background
she was stunned
and relieved
to know that instead of thinking less of
her
they thought more of her for triumphing
over challenging circumstances
these are what yellies are like
although after all there are hard
aspects of life
but they can be made less difficult
by the openness
and sharing
for which yale students are so generally
known
yale students pearson wrote are not
loners
are not solitary
they are part
of each other
as a product of the american dream
myself
i am inspired by it
and i'm committed
to preserving it
and while admitting that it has been
idealized historically and perhaps
compromised in contemporary society
i am convinced
that yours can be the generation
that ensures it is kept alive
and i mean that whether you come from
pittsburgh
or pretoria
or ponce
i am thankful that yale's financial aid
policies and practices sustain and
propel this promise
and allow so many of you to access
the american dream
but more than that
i am thankful that a yale education
helps to develop
the habits of mind and behavior
that will first lead you to
uncomfortable and challenging
conversations
and then motivate you
to make
constructive contributions to your
professions
and to your families
to your countries
and to the world
yours can be the generation that helps
to develop
a more complex vision of the american
dream
one that moves beyond social mobility
and also includes living a life
of growth
of meaning
and of significance
affordable education and opportunities
for fulfilling work
are essential for this vision
it is my hope though
indeed my conviction
that you will continue to ensure
that the dream
of a better life
will be woven permanently
into the fabric of our societies
around the world
so
however it is that you arrived here at
yale
on behalf of all my colleagues on the
platform here this morning
welcome parents
welcome families
and welcome
class of 2017.
yes
foreign
foreign
boys
uh
three
uh
is
is
oh
with uh
my sisters and brothers
as we prepare to step out onto new
ground
in this daunting
yet inspiring liminal space
of the unknown next
we begin a poignant turn of goodbyes and
hellos that invite laughter tears
discovery and pride
let us go forth with deep trust
in certain knowledge
that love surrounds us
that beauty can surprise us
that truth and light awaits us
on this day and ever more
may all that is holy shine upon us
and tenderly bless
our every breath
may we go in shalom
in salam
in shanti
may we go
in peace
amen
you